as i have indicated previously this week
the scottish government is
legally required to review the
regulations giving
effect to the lockdown every three weeks
and
the latest review falls due today
our assessment of the evidence leads me
to the conclusion
that the lockdown must be extended at
this stage
more detail of our analysis will be
published alongside today's daily
statistics at 2 pm
but let me say this now we are
together making really significant
progress
in our efforts to get this virus under
control i have
reported today a further reduction in
the number of patients in intensive care
and yesterday national records of
scotland reported the first
weekly decline in the number of
registered deaths related to the virus
since this outbreak began all of that
gives us real hope and real
encouragement
but we also know that progress remains
fragile
our estimates suggest that there are
still significant numbers of people
in scotland infected with this virus
and we're not yet confident that the
all-important
our number is comfortably below one and
i've
explained and set out before why it is
so important to get it
and keep it comfortably below one indeed
we think it could still be hovering
around one just now which means that any
significant easing up
of restrictions at this stage would be
very
very risky indeed